you remember when president trump during
the campaign posted that meme
to twitter and it was a picture of him
and it said
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you
and i just happen to be in the way i
thought it was one of the high
points of the 2020 campaign and jack
dorsey
twitter ceo just proved it true
jack dorsey obviously just de-platformed
president trump
the other day he was just caught on a
hidden camera i believe from project
veritas
uh pointing out on a phone call this is
not about trump
the censorship is going to be much much
broader
we do intend to do a full retro as i
said in my
it is going to take some time um and
then
the other thing just to just to close
out
a little bit we you know we we are
focused on one account right now
but this is going to be much bigger than
just one account
and it's going to go on for much longer
than just this day this week
in the next few weeks it's going to go
on beyond the inauguration
we have to expect that we have to be
ready for that so
the focus is certainly on this account
and how it ties to real world violence
but also we need to think much longer
term
around how these dynamics play out over
time
i don't believe this is going away
anytime soon
and the moves that we're making today
around
uh for instance is one such example of a
much broader
approach that we should be looking at
and going deeper on so the team has
a lot of work and a lot of focus on this
particular issue
we also need to give them the space and
the support to focus on
the much bigger picture much bigger much
broader you see he's using the excuse of
real real-world violence
to take trump off of twitter it doesn't
really justify it at all doesn't
it doesn't explain the real world
violence that trump is inciting
right trump is tweeting out saying be
peaceful be peaceful be peaceful
but he's basically admitting that's just
an excuse because this is going to be
much broader
then he says okay and then we're going
to broaden out and talk about q
anon but even that that's not the extent
of it this is going to be
much much broader it's going to go on
for weeks and months
it's going to go on past the
inauguration
big tech the ruling liberal regime of
which big tech plays a
plays a role has had it with
conservatives and they want to
ostracize us from society i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
welcome back to the michael knowles show
my favorite comment from yesterday from
va fan
who says trump is a type a personality
i'm sure he's thinking
if clinton can be impeached once i can
one-up him
i can get impeached twice he's my kind
of president you know i think that's
absolutely true
anything you can do i can do better and
it is true we made this point yesterday
on the show
if trump had only been impeached once
that might
tarnish his legacy i'm not sure that it
would but it might but
the fact that he was impeached twice by
these same crooks
in many ways to me seems to help his
legacy
that they hate him so much he's such a
threat to them
in their minds that they had to impeach
him
twice i i suspect the history books will
look kindly
on that double impeachment by the way if
you're a history buff
or if you just want to learn generally
you've got to check out
the great courses 2020 was full of
unique
challenges that made us change our whole
way of life but with
each challenge we learned to survive
thrive
and strive to be better we do not know
what 2021 will bring
but with the great courses plus we can
make this our year by continuing to
learn with purpose
because when we learn with purpose we
can do better be better and with great
courses plus
the opportunities to learn are endless
you get unlimited access to stream
thousands of video
and audio courses from top experts in
their fields
like how to build a better financial
plan how to control stress and make it
work for you
even play guitar like a pro and for me
so there's all those practical courses
those don't appeal to me i want the
least practical courses there's a great
one on 1066
the battle of hastings is something i
love great one on the middle ages
uh just really terrific and it's you can
you can start listening then you turn it
off that app you then watch the rest on
tv
it kind of replaces your episodes at
night if you want it's just terrific
what's your purpose this year
sign up for the great courses plus and
find out
visit my special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles you will get an entire month of
unlimited access for free
you do not want to pass this up so go to
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles that is thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles i'm a big fan of this product
of this organization a really great way
to
pass some time you know whether you're
you've got 15 minutes here 30 minutes
here
for me i think it's a great substitute
for tv shows and things like that
streaming at night
i gotta go check out the great courses
they say make your own twitter if you're
a conservative and then you make your
own twitter
and they kick you off of the internet
parlor tried this
parlor was dan bongino's platform you
know there was the twitter alternative
then they they go and you know they're
getting a lot of new members when
twitter starts purging right wingers
and then amazon web services kicks
parlor off we were told that parlor was
supposed to be back today
parlor is not back today parlor
according to its ceo
may never return why is it
is it because parlor just doesn't have a
good business model
i don't think so i think parlor can
attract a lot of money i mean you've
heard
people uh financial analysts talking
about how well parlor is doing
is it because parlor doesn't have a good
user base
no parlor last i checked had 2.3 million
active users and 15 million total users
and that by the way was before this
crazy week of
kicking trump off of twitter and
everybody going over to parlor so i'm
sure that number went up
considerably many multiples perhaps well
it's not because of that
it's because the left does not want the
right to have
any say they want the right to be
totally ostracized it's not about trump
that is a distraction it's not about cue
anon
that is a distraction it's about you
it's about the 75 million trump voters
people who mainstream leftists have said
are nazis neo-nazi white supremacists
and therefore totally should should not
be permitted in society
it's it's interesting on a few levels
how this works because what they do
they've been doing this for a long time
they call you deplorable irredeemable
bitter clingers right all these sort of
ways to
dismiss you and and justify taking you
out of society
but the the top charge probably is that
you're a nazi
right you've been hearing this ever
since gore vidal was debating bill
buckley
many many years ago he said you're a
crypto nazi and bill buckley threatened
to punch him in his face
they call you nazis because that that is
in popular culture considered the
embodiment the incarnation of pure evil
right there can be nothing
even close to that amount of evil
why is communism not considered on that
level
communism a bloodier ideology
right and and certainly i think in the
ballpark of
wickedness and how pernicious these
ideologies are right
why is it perfectly fine to be a
communist why are you permitted to wear
a che guevara t-shirt could you imagine
if you were a nazi t-shirt oh my
goodness gracious
but you can wear che guevara you can
wear chairman mao you could probably
wear a stalin t-shirt on a college
campus
wouldn't get you into any sort of
trouble
it's a strange strange double standard
meanwhile the 75 million americans who
voted for trump
are not nazis but it doesn't matter
because if you just say
75 million people disagree with me
they're not liberals they're not very
progressive
then it's hard to justify kicking them
not just off of social media but out of
banks
out of their jobs out of their
livelihoods right but if you say they're
nazis then yeah sure we don't want we
don't want to do business with
hitler do we all of this of course
in the final days of the trump first
term
some people saying the trump
administration he could run again unless
they somehow convict him
uh impeach and convict which they're not
going to do in the next few days
but all of this we hear time and time
and time again
is uh i guess the the only other
superlative not just to say they're
nazis or
white supremacists the other thing that
you hear all the time
is that this is worse than watergate and
for our daily worse than watergate
analysis
we turn to left-wing hack carl bernstein
who sort of was involved in watergate
and has made an entire career out of it
the nixon comparison part of your
reporting is interesting we wanted to
bring in
someone who masterfully told the story
of nixon's final days carl bernstein the
investigative journalist
is also now a cnn political analyst carl
president trump lashing out over
comparisons to nixon is
is particularly interesting and in many
ways you and i talked about this i
think it was last night the the end to
this presidency
you were saying is much worse than
nixon's
well first of all nixon was not a
secessionist
seditious president of the united states
who inspired and celebrated
uh in a riot to burn down the capital
which is really what occurred he
encouraged it
uh those people went there because of
his incitement
uh nixon was was in a different category
in that regard
he was a real criminal president uh who
deserved
uh having to leave office and
republicans got him out of office
forced his resignation very different
than what we've seen with trump the
republicans
have enabled him and allowed him to stay
in office
so that isn't true first of all
obviously trump did not call for a riot
at the capitol he did not
incite all of this violence the things
that carl bernstein are saying
are just not true which is typical of
carl bernstein
but beyond all of that i just
cannot believe at this point when they
bring
this old hack out once a week
practically to do the same shtick
it is it is a vaudeville routine at this
point they drag out carl bernstein
and with some sort of they give whatever
the setup is and then his role
like like a good little charlie mccarthy
doll is to go out and say worse than
watergate this is worse than watergate
but they
that they can all do it with a straight
face is astounding to me it shows you
their showbiz professionalism
so you know uh we're gonna bring on carl
bernstein now cnn contributor
and uh you know carl there have been
some comparisons uh between
donald trump and richard nixon and uh
but
you know carl i was so shocked i was so
amazed you you've recently said that
maybe
president trump is worse than richard
nixon are you carl are you
saying this might be worse than
watergate
carl are you hold on i just want to make
sure i'm following this correctly are
you saying
the same and only thing that you have
said on television for 40 years
uh yes anderson i am saying that orange
man
bad bad bad worse than watergate bad bad
bad
oh wow great analysis carl thank you so
much
for coming on deja vu
all over again second verse same as the
first
what a corrupt what a shallow
what an embarrassing ruling elite we
have
and and they all they justify anything i
mean they're going to call for trump's
head
before he leaves office they're going to
impeach him seven more times
they're going to say they're going to
take away all of his money they're
already talking about that
they're going to investigate him they're
going to say they're going to throw him
in prison just get
get to the point which is that you want
some marie antoinette style
regicide or something i mean that is
that is the direction
the left is moving at the very least
they want to tar and feather the guy
and all of this is justified how because
he's a nazi and worse than watergate and
he's a white supremacist and
he incited violence and of course
that none of that's true and ironically
the left actually did incite violence by
providing material support
to the blm riots and
explicitly encouraging physical violence
but none of that matters and we are told
as a result we need to kick trump off
twitter kick him out of society and
ostracize all of his followers too not
just q anon
but all of them it's gonna be much much
bigger than that in the words of jack
dorsey
believe it or not some people outside
this country even on the left
see what kind of a game this is they see
what kind of a dangerous
trick this is from the ruling elite even
the
left-wing president of mexico is calling
them out and pointing out this danger
and with all of these troubles that
we've got today it's very important
to get a good night's sleep and that's
why i love my pillow
you know mike lindell he is the inventor
of my pillow
not just my pillow but my pillow the
brand uh he's a very very cool guy and
super conservative
so i would have supported him anyway in
his company but then
the thing is his pillow is the greatest
pillow i've ever used in my whole life
they don't go flat i don't know how
they've managed to achieve this they
just don't go flat
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want they maintain their shape
best of all they're made here in the usa
bestest of all
even bester of all they're extremely
comfortable right now you can get a
queen size
premium my pillow regularly 69.98 it's
only
29.98 that's 40 in savings kings are
only 5
more now is the time to buy you won't
regret it seriously if
you spend a lot of time sleeping get the
best pillow you can
mike's going to extend his 60-day money
back guarantee to march 1st 2021. it
doesn't matter you're not gonna
return the pillow so it's kind of a moot
point go to mypillow.com and click on
the radio listeners square there you
will find not only this amazing offer
but also deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets
you can also call 800-651-1148 use promo
code
daily wire you know how great my pillow
is it's why i feel so fresh and rested
every day
even when i don't get that many hours of
sleep my my pillow feels so good
that i get to feel great coming to do
this show every single day go check them
out
mexico's left-wing president andres
manuel
lopez obrador has now promised
to take on the big tech companies he
says quote i can tell you that at the
first g20 meeting we have
i'm going to make a proposal on this
issue
he's not just taking on big tech in the
abstract he wants to take on big
tech because they kicked off president
trump
specifically it but we're told
all left-wingers have to hate president
trump and want to ostracize him versus
from society
but we're told mexico especially has to
hate president trump but we're told he's
an evil villain nazi
klansman whatever well this left-wing
president of mexico gets it
sees through all of this bs being pushed
to you by corporate media
he says yes social media should not be
used to incite violence and all that
i love the dismissal yeah and all that
and all that but this cannot be used as
a pretext
to suspend freedom of expression how can
a company act as if it was all-powerful
omnipotent as a sort of spanish
inquisition on what is expressed
great question now
he's speaking as a politician there i'd
be willing actually to grant
social media companies a little bit more
than that they obviously have to cut
certain content down as we said we all
agree
you know if there are direct threats or
direct incitement of violence okay that
we agree we should take it down
what about obscenity we've always had
laws
and sort of customs in this country
against obscenity
for important reasons you know there's
there's the think of the children
argument which is you don't want kids to
get hooked on naughty images when
they're very young
especially if they're you know
high-speed videos or things that are
really going to mess with your head a
lot more than like a playboy
you know under your brother's mattress
or something uh
but so there's that kind of argument
against obscenity there's also a deeper
political argument against obscenity
and it's the sort of thing our founding
fathers made sort of arguments our
founding fathers made which is that
when you're living in a culture that
believes that licentiousness is liberty
you're going to lose your discipline
you're going to lose your virtue you're
going to lose your faculties of reason
and you're not going to be capable of
liberty forget
forget be deserving of liberty you won't
even even be capable of
having it so you've got to make sure you
reign in some of those base passions
so that you have your higher faculties
you're more in command of your body
you're thinking with your brain and not
with other parts of your body
uh so i think we generally agree with
that i mean even the tech platforms have
always sort of done that right instagram
has a no porn policy i think
i don't know i guess i don't know if
twitter does but
there have always been some of these
policies
i'm sure we would all suggest other
aspects too
one thing i think we ought to all agree
on at least i i somehow agree with the
left-wing president of mexico
and i agree with angela merkel on this
in germany and i agree with other world
leaders
this hipster rasputin weirdo
jack dorsey in silicon valley a grown
man with a nose ring
should not have the ability to
censor the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
something has gone seriously wrong if
that has happened
and if he is going to continue down this
very destructive
path a path that is a great danger to
our country
then we should use the full power of our
politics
to stop him from doing that not just a
conservative opinion also
an opinion that some liberals share not
just an american opinion but
an opinion that foreign leaders share
that is a threat to the global order
if some creepy billionaire weirdo with a
nose ring
can censor duly elected world leaders
we need to have some kind of standards
we can't pretend that
free free expression just lives in the
abstract there's never been such a thing
as unlimited free expression
free speech that has just been without
bounds it's never happened anywhere
it's because this is a finite world and
we have our finite people and we have to
have order in society so it's
not possible we can have broader
versions of it or narrower versions of
it we have a very robust system of free
speech in america
we should preserve that but we should
recognize that there are some limits on
this i'll give you i'll give you a great
example
there's a story out about a mother kyle
i think her
her name is kyle kyle myers
she is a utahn i i thought people from
utah were very conservative apparently
not this lady
she's the mother of a four-year-old
child who refuses to disclose whether
the child is a boy or a girl
and she says she's going to let the
child decide
his own gender i say his because his
is the uh singular gender neutral
pronoun
and this mother has now been accused of
child abuse
here's her take on it she says my
partner brent and i
not husband not boyfriend partner like
she's started an accounting firm or
something
my partner brent and i do something
called gender creative parenting
i believe gender is up to an individual
to determine and does not need to be
assigned at birth
i know a lot of people who are intersex
transgender and non-binary
i myself am a genderqueer woman who uses
they them
and she her pronouns so first of all
this woman is not genderqueer because
there's no such thing as genderqueer
it's a
meaningless expression and i think what
genderqueer really means is give me
attention
i'm a give me attention woman and i'm
really special give me attention
uh she says she knows a lot of intersex
transgender and non-binary people
she doesn't know any non-binary people
because that's not real she might know
some intersex you know that's where
you're born with some ambiguity as to
your
sex uh it's an exceedingly rare
condition
uh and she might know so she may
certainly know some transgender people
men who think they're women or vice
versa
but she doesn't know a lot of them and
the way i know she doesn't know a lot of
them is there aren't a lot of them
because it's an extraordinarily
rare condition certainly the the
biological ambiguity on sex
is very rare and the psychological issue
is has been rare though it is growing by
leaps and bounds because
it has not only a psychological or
biological component but it has
a social component and it is a growing
as a social contagion particularly among
young people who are being abused by
their elders who should know better
like this lady's child gender creative
you cannot have a functioning society
in which there is normal parenting
and gender creative parenting you can't
have at least on a
broad scale you can't have a functioning
society because
those two expressions
make contrary ontological claims
to they make contrary uh
they begin from contrary premises about
nature
about biology about the human person
about how we all
interact with one another about how
education
happens right do you do you teach
children do you educate them do you
raise them in a certain way or do they
in a sense teach you
and then discover haphazardly the
reality of the world
right completely different views of
things she says
i believe gender is up to an individual
it's not it's not
it is a given fact of nature and nature
doesn't change
i suspect this lady believes nature can
change which means it's not really
nature anymore
uh and it does not need to be assigned
at birth i am a genderqueer woman
no uh how can you be genderqueer and a
woman doesn't doesn't make a lot of
sense says i use they them
and she her pronouns well which is it is
she
multiple people maybe she might she
perhaps she has
issues with multiple personalities as
well she would appear to she's saying
i am two kinds of person at the same
time
if you have a society in which
men can be women and women can be men
then you don't have a society in which
men are men and women are women
and that has huge effects like
for instance actually i remember andrew
sullivan wrote andrew sullivan is a gay
sort of conservative writer
he wrote an essay a few years ago in
which he pointed this out he said if we
live in a society
with transgenderism then i can't be a
gay guy
and i can't be a gay guy because the
premises that i'm beginning with
are there are men and there are women
and sexual orientation
has a very strong biological component
to it it's sort of hardwired in and i'm
born this way and you know i didn't
choose this or whatever
and so therefore i'm a gay guy right
if you live in the transgender world
there's no such thing as men or women
and it's not hardwired in not only can
you change your desires
you can change your sex itself you can
be a man
and then become a woman you can't live
in a functioning society with both of
those things
the reason that the left has sort of
encouraged all these various
contradictory new
standards and ethics is because
they attack the old system right and
with the the left when they wield
political correctness
it's a negative instrument it's an
instrument to just destroy the old
system
the old standards the old rituals the
old morays the old moral order
so it doesn't matter if they contradict
one another as long as you destroy the
old order you've
you've kind of accomplished your goal
but that is child abuse either it is
for this woman either it is child abuse
to
tell your child he doesn't have a sex
and he can pick it later on or it is
child abuse
to tell your child he has a sex and it
depends which premise you begin with but
you cannot have
both if you want to
think back on a time that was maybe a
little more orderly made a little bit
more sense
highly recommend paint your life i love
paint your life
great way to have some memories of
people of places of pets
preserved by tremendous artists i love
them i just had one done in my mother
and the portrait is stunning it's
absolutely stunning so pleased that i'll
be able to
hang it up in my house if you want to
give a truly
meaningful gift you've got to check out
paintyourlife.com
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price you wouldn't believe
how affordable these prices are you
choose from a team of world-class
artists you work with them until every
detail is perfect
their user-friendly platform lets you
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
quick and easy process and you get that
hand-painted portrait in about three
weeks you send in
any picture of yourself of your family
of your kids of your
special place you like you can even
combine photos so you say i want this
from this and this from that
it makes a great birthday gift or
anniversary gift or wedding gift
i've given it as a wedding gift i've
also just given it as a me gift
because their work is so beautiful and
we understand how important it is to be
surrounded by beautiful things makes
your life a lot better
at paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money will be refunded but you're going
to love it
guaranteed you get your money refunded
but you're going to love it right now
is a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that is
20 off and free shipping to get this
offer text the word michael to 64
000 that is michael to 64 000 mich ael
to 64 000. paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most
term supply available at painterlife.com
terms text michael to 64
000. i've had uh portraits done for my
step brothers
uh wedding that looks unbelievable i got
a portrait of drew i don't i don't hang
that up in my it'd be kind of weird if i
had a picture of drew hang up in my
house
but really really beautiful stuff go
check them out also speaking of drew
the new andrew clavin show starts today
uh you know there was a little bit of a
break drew's show used to be
what was it four days a week and then it
went down to uh
zero days a week while we were all
moving and figuring things out
now there's going to be a one day a week
show it's going to be 90 minutes they're
going to be guests it's going to be
tremendous just had a stogie with drew
last night
while we were watching the premiere of
run hide fight
which was our first movie that the daily
wire is launching our first
venture into entertainment content if
you missed it we had the big premiere
last night everyone got to see it
you can watch it you can stream it
whenever you want you got to go to
dailywire.com
uh you can watch it right now the movie
uh really terrific film
we got to chat with the producer and the
director last night
or who are great guys and uh i've been
reading the reviews all over social
media it seems that people
universally love it except for like one
media matters troll
who didn't like it which is perfect to
me that's the best review you could get
everyone else seems to really really
enjoy it so
you know 50 million viewers can't be
wrong or whatever 50 million frenchmen
can't be wrong
head on over go check it out um we are
really excited to bring you great
stories that hollywood refuses to tell
and we hope that you'll join us and
become a daily wire member today
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
so you know that what happened at the
capitol is not just bad which we all
agree
not just condemnable which we all agree
on
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in the history of america much
worse than pearl harbor
and it was only only right-wingers there
were no
left-wingers that were involved at all
they did happen to arrest a blm activist
who was there but
forget about that and he was on cnn but
no that's not a big not a big deal
that actually it is the case i think
they were mostly right-wingers right
uh and very bad thing
but we did just have a whole year of
political violence from the left didn't
we we did just have a whole year of blm
burning down city after city after city
torching businesses killing dozens of
people we did just have
antifa a radical left organization set
up
a sort of sovereign city
right a city state called the chaz the
capitol hill
authorized zone is that was that or
independent zone or such
that would be chis i guess who knows it
was this
radical left-wing social experiment that
was tolerated it was perfectly tolerated
for quite a long time a lot of this
stuff
has come out of portland ted wheeler
mayor of portland
has come out come under a lot of fire
because he has
tolerated and you might even say
encouraged
through his negligence and through his
ideological
declarations this kind of left-wing
violence that's plagued portland
and the surrounding areas so one
intrepid local news host
was interviewing mayor wheeler and said
you know yeah we all agree capitol hill
that thing's really bad but don't you
think uh
you're uh permitting this left-wing
violence to go on for so long don't you
think that might have had
i don't know something to do with it
three weeks ago protesters broke into
the oregon state capitol i have heard
people at these protests elsewhere
saying well they let it happen in
portland so why not do it here
it seems in some way the actions of
these small groups that you're referring
to
have set the stage for what has happened
on a state level and potentially a
national level i know you said
it will take time to crack down on these
groups but do we have that time
are you blaming me for what happened at
the u.s capitol
are you wait a minute are you are you
saying that because i've uh permitted
and one might even say encourage the
violence
from the left here and that the left
broadly has has encouraged violence for
months and months and months and
burned down sea to shining sea are you
saying that might have something to do
with the mostly right-wing
violence that took place for a few hours
at the capitol
that is what we're saying i'm glad that
you are hearing what we're saying
because for a week now the left is
deflected and they've said no that's
what a baptism
no it's only right-wing violence no it's
completely different no it's not
it's not it's not it's bad to like
go attack the capital for a few hours
that is bad it's much much worse to burn
the country down for several months
it's bad to go in and disrupt the
offices
of members of congress it's worse
to destroy many many many many many
business owners livelihoods and
buildings and property
and lives in some cases that is what
we're talking about
we are blaming you ted wheeler
and we're blaming you maxine waters who
called for violence and we're blaming
you
chris cuomo who defended political
violence
and we're blaming you hillary clinton
who said you can't be civil with your
opponents
and we're blaming all of you guys you
did this
donald trump didn't do this donald trump
didn't do this
at all some trump supporters
did some political violence
for a few hours at the capitol that was
bad
after months and months and months of
what
you did of what you did the double
standards are insane
there's a story there's a story i wanted
to get to
a few days ago this is from actually
from january 7th
a chattanooga uh assistant football
coach was fired
because he sent a hateful tweet about
stacey abrams
i'm not like a huge football fan
generally so i don't i don't really know
who this guy is
but uh he's uh he's an offensive line
coach
and he posted this this uh social media
thing
where he mocked stacey abrams's
appearance and
quote falsely claimed there was cheating
in georgia elections
and that's why he was fired so the tweet
says uh congratulations to the state
georgia and fat albert stacey abrams
called her fat albert
that's not nice that's mean you know
don't don't do that
uh hey hey hey don't do that uh because
you have truly shown america the true
works of cheating in an election again
enjoy the buffet big girl you earned it
hope the money is good still not
governor
uh you know i actually i do think it's
very distasteful to uh
mock people's appearances i i really
don't like that stuff
um so obviously the left has been doing
this now for how long they're calling
big fat orange man
and all sorts of mean names about trump
none of them would ever lose their job
for that and if they're not going to
lose their job i don't think this guy
should lose his job for making a
sort of distasteful physical joke about
the not governor of georgia but that's
the part
that's the part that i want to focus on
the report here from the associated
press says
this guy chris malone was fired because
he mocked abram's appearance
and falsely claimed there was cheating
in georgia elections
so if you if you should be fired
for falsely claiming that there was
cheating in georgia's elections
don't you think this should not not only
apply to the person who mocked stacey
abrams but to um
stacy abrams herself who has claimed for
years
falsely that there was cheating in her
election how do they write this stuff
and not see what they're saying how do
you write a piece about how it's
absolutely horrible to criticize
stacey abrams and simultaneously claim
there's cheating in georgia's elections
when stacey abrams has been doing that
for years
it doesn't matter because stacey abrams
is good
and this guy is bad because stacey
abrams
is a liberal and she checks a lot of
intersectional
grievance group boxes and this guy
is bad because he's a conservative and
he doesn't check those intersectional
grievance group boxes
and so it's it's not even obviously
there's a double standard
but it is good it is positively good
to fire him and it would be very very
bad to take out
stacey abrams from whatever her job is i
don't even know what her job is right
now other than
political shenanigans that's what we're
seeing
jack dorsey is not going to clamp down
on the left folks
and it's i guess there's a double
standard but here's his standard
right wing bad left-wing good right
we're not going to take off the violent
accounts on the left we are going to
take off the
much broader than violent accounts on
the right it's not just trump it's not
just q anon it's
a lot of people even after the election
his words not mine let's get to the
mailbag
derek says hey michael i have an
interesting thought experiment for
you if a person wanted a custom cake
to say something like trump hero of the
republic do you think a leftist bakery
would make it
worth testing i think thanks for all
your good work uh probably they wouldn't
they wouldn't make it but they wouldn't
have to make it because
we have certain legal protections in
this country and they
protect religious views though they
don't protect them very well but at
least on the books they protect
religious views
they protect sex
but now they also protect sexual
orientation and gender identity
which is ironic because that undermines
sex right the idea if you're
if you this is the issue with the girl
sports right is
if you have a protection on the basis of
sex that means that the girls get to
have their own sports leagues
but if you have a legal protection on
the basis of gender identity that means
girls don't get to have their own sports
leagues because the boys can play in the
girls sports leagues
so they're very contradictory but
nowhere in any of those protections
do you have a protection for political
point of view
so you're out unfortunately you can go
there they'll turn you down supreme
court
wouldn't hear the case from brooklyn hey
michael my name is brooklyn
i knew that because you because it was
in the name line my name is brooklyn i'm
from illinois
i started by listening to the ben
shapiro show and now find myself
addicted to your show i'm very pleased
to hear that brooklyn my question is
about whether you think
as conservatives it would be more
effective for us to outright
ban using the big tech apps twitter
facebook youtube
or if we should remain on these
platforms for as long as we can
and share as much conservative stuff as
possible to reach out to others
until we are forcibly removed thanks i
don't think this is an either or
scenario
you said should we use the government to
crack
the unprecedented power
of big tech to control our political
conversation
and therefore to control our politics
and our republic in a republic
speeches politics and politics is speech
if these guys have the right to censor
the duly elected president that's too
much power
they have the right to censor half of
the political conversation that's too
much power so
do we use the state to bring big tech
down to size
and point out that they're getting legal
protections like in
according to section 230 that they
should not be getting and
point out that maybe they've engaged in
some fraud in the way that they've
gained
critical mass and market share and then
kind of switch the
the ball game uh should we do that or
should we stay on social media and i
think uh both
we should stay on social media for as
long as we can and we should continue to
affect the public conversation for as
long as we can
and simultaneously we should try to
break these guys up and bring them down
to size
those are not contradictory things this
is a trick the left always
tries to make us fall into which is
they they want us to remove ourselves
from the conversation they want us to
play by a set of rules that they will
not play by
but the thing about politics is the same
thing that can be said of war
your opponent gets a say you don't get
to pick every single circumstance
of politics or war you've got to
to to use a cliche you've got to play
the hand you're dealt all right how many
more metaphors can i mix
you you've got to deal in the
circumstances that you're in right now
the circumstance we're in is that big
tech
controls the political conversation and
that's a bad thing and we've got to
fight against that
but one of the ways in which we can
fight against that is by using
those systems against big tech for as
long as they'll tolerate us and we
should we should take an
all of the above strategy from caleb
michael i just subscribed about 10
minutes before writing this and am
excited to receive my tumblr so that i
can consume those salty and delicious
tears
simple question if you had to pick today
what republican candidate do you see
having the best chance of unseating joe
biden in 2024
if it's still joe biden by then let's
not forget the guy's pretty up there in
age
so you know i these days i guess i'm
hoping he
lasts quite a while because kamala
harris is so uh
awful but uh who knows we could be
running against biden or against kamal
in 2024 just
looking at life expectancies in the
united states for the sake of argument
let's assume both trump and kanye are
off the table
also you should have won an emmy for
another kingdom hashtag came for ben
state for michael thank you very much
who do i think is the 2024 guy i don't
know it would be very hard
to have picked trump in 2012. right four
years before the 2016 race
so i'm not sure obviously i am uh
friends with ted cruz and i
strongly think he should run and i would
encourage him to run for president i
don't know i don't have any don't have
any insider information as to whether
that would happen
um but i i hope he does and i would
encourage him to
uh ron desantis in florida seems like he
would he would be running
um he would be he'd be a good choice or
at least it seems like he'd be a good
choice we don't we don't know as much
about him because he's kind of newer on
the political scene
but you know he's done a great job down
in florida uh
josh hawley appears like he wants to run
i guess
you know similar thing to ron desantis
he's saying and doing some interesting
things we just don't we don't know a ton
about him that's the purpose of a
primary campaign is to vet some of these
candidates
it would appear that nikki haley wants
to run she's kind of positioned herself
in a way where she could run
christie gnome in south dakota it would
appear that she kind of wants to run
i think it's going to be important i i'm
not going to i mean i
you know i'm i'm encouraging senator
cruz to run for president i hope he does
uh but beyond the kind of horse race of
this person or that person i think more
broadly
i think that the kind of person who
could win the nomination and the
presidency in 2024
the kind of person who should win the
nomination and the presidency in 2024
is going to have to be someone who can
make a credible claim to trump voters
not just the establishment squishes not
just the old kind of bushy foreign
policy
conservative types who want you know to
invade every country around the world
uh but but people who can make a
credible claim who are not just going to
regurgitate the platitudes of the 90s
and early 2000s and so i think there are
you know at least i'd say two or three
candidates right now that could
could sort of make that claim and who
knows others might
might emerge and uh obviously we got
four years to do it
but that's the the only way it's going
to work i know that there are many
conservatives right now
who are praying that the trump faction
of the conservative movement is going to
disappear it's not going to disappear
guys
it's been around for a long time before
it was the trump movement it was called
the tea party
before it was the tea party it was the
cultural conservatives you know of the
of the 2000s and the 90s before that
they were the reaganites
before that they were the goldwater
people and
it's a very sad fact that
uh people today who claim the mantle of
ronald reagan very often
are are not like ronald reagan ronald
reagan was much more conservative than
they were
many people today who claim the mantle
of william f buckley jr
invoke him all the time they don't seem
to read a lot of william f buckley jr
you know they they see
they the time that has elapsed since
they were in politics
has weakened their memory has made them
seem kind of squishy
there has always been on the right a
conservative side and a squish side and
uh the conservative side now kind of old
school conservative side is going with
trump
and i know there are all these arguments
about the true conservatives and
to be a true conservative you just have
to be super duper
liberal and libertarian on everything
well no that that historian just
historically is not true
it's changed political circumstances
change all the time but those two sides
of the republican party
and of the right generally those have
persisted for decade upon decade and
you're going to call it the trump people
now it's going to be called something
else in
in five years but that side what what
that represents
that is not going away and if you want
to make a credible run
i know there are a lot of people think
the way to win the presidency is to
nominate some squish
from the liberal republican side of
things
how has that worked out historically
bush 41 only won because he got reagan's
third term and then he lost
george w bush ran as a conservative
might not have been super hardcore but
he was more hardcore than his dad
john mccain ran as a liberal republican
mitt romney ran as a liberal republican
donald trump ran as a conservative
republican
make of that what you will uh
that's that's gonna if you want to be a
credible candidate you've got to appeal
to the to the conservatives to the base
from simeon what a great name i am
currently in the market for a new job
i was recently in consideration for an
engineering management position at
procter gamble
the day of my interview however my
conscience got the better of me and
chose to rescind my application due to
the utter embarrassment i would feel
working for such a socially just company
did i make the right decision
or is the best way to effect change from
the inside out thanks
i am not going to give you a principled
answer here i'm going to give you a
prudential answer because prudence is
one of my principles and it's a virtue
and we should follow it
you've got to get into the specifics
here what what is your goal
in your professional career and what is
your
circumstance for instance
uh t.s eliot
did not make his sort of career
his career and what i mean by that is
t.s eliot one of the great poets of the
last
100 years a little earlier than that
t.s eliot worked at a bank
and his that was his day job he just
worked at a bank and then he
wrote some of the greatest last great
poems in the english language
dana joya who's a living poet i really
like dana joy's work
he just worked at like a corporation he
was just like a marketing guy to
corporation he went to business school
and he's one of the great living poets
his day job was not what he felt he was
really called to do and
you might ask the same for you what are
you doing what do you you know is it
just you're going to go get a paycheck
and then you're going to go write
beautiful poetry
well then i guess it doesn't really
matter if you're working at procter
gamble or whatever is it that you want
to have an effect
on the way this company is moving
whether it's in a very limited way or
even if it's in a larger way
well maybe you can do that at procter
gamble maybe you can't is procter gamble
really a super left-wing company
or did they just make a bunch of bs
commercials to try to fool the woke
people i don't know
i mean you'd have to know from the
inside of proctor and gamble what is the
effect of proctor and gamble on the
world uh
you know i can't answer your question
because
the question does not permit a simple
ideological bumper sticker answer you've
got to get into the circumstances of
these things
and i think one reason conservatives
have failed to really capture a lot of
the culture
is we refuse we refuse to get into this
kind of nitty gritty
we just want like three bumper sticker
maxims at least for the past 15 20 years
and that that ain't how politics works
that's not how political and cultural
change works
from jennifer hey michael a few years
ago i asked you a mailbag question about
the moral dilemma of having taken plan b
after being sexually assaulted i
remember it very
very well good to hear from you again in
your kindness you told me to focus on
healing from the trauma first
enough time has passed and i think i'm
quite strong enough now to ask you again
from one catholic to another how sinful
is it to take plan b
in such a circumstance or in any
circumstance is it considered an
abortion drug and if it is should i
confess this as such to a priest
thank you as always i love your show
thank you very much it's so good to hear
from you again i remember that was years
ago that you asked me that question
i was still back in my broom closet i
think at the old studio in la
uh the short answer is i don't know i
don't know
as a moral matter i can't i just don't
have the authority to give you really an
answer on that i can give you
my views of things in my opinion as i
understand it but
when in doubt confess you know when in
doubt go to a priest
um and i also don't know because plan b
is very
unclear in the way that it it operates
so plan b is the morning after pill
they call it emergency contraception but
it can be an abortifacient drug
because plan b does three things it can
prevent
ovulation no abortion though i guess
the use of contraceptives at all would
constitute
sin you know according to catholicism so
you should you should confess that too
obviously different degrees um but you
uh can prevent ovulation so not an
abortion
it can block fertilization of an egg
not an abortion or it can keep a
fertilized egg from implanting in the
universe
which according to secular liberalism is
not an abortion but according to the
catholic church
it is an abortion because the catholic
church believes that life begins at
conception
not at implantation so
i i don't know the statistics you know
two out of three ways that this operates
it would not have induced an abortion uh
one way
it could have induced an abortion and so
i i would just recommend genera you are
simply not going to be able to know what
happened
uh and you can try to look into the
statistics of what is most statistically
likely but
it will involve what time of the month
it was and all these other sorts of
questions that probably you just
wouldn't know
when in doubt you should avail yourself
of the great grace that is before all of
us which is confession
i know for some non-catholics don't
really they think confession is kind of
weird
a way to think of it in the catholic
view of things is that it's like a
laundromat for the soul
uh i would go in and and bring it up and
it just
as a matter not not only of
psychological healing which of course it
does but as a matter of spiritual
healing i would avail yourself of that
as well i'm
very pleased to hear you're doing much
better now and it's so good to hear from
you
from bradley michael i finally became an
all-access member i'm excited to help
you guys grow and see what the future
holds for the daily wire
as a veteran i see everything i fought
for going down the drain i see our
country going the wrong direction
i'm curious to see what you think of the
biden administration what they'll do if
they have control of everything
what agenda are they going to put up and
pass without fail considering the
support they have now thanks
for everything you do i think they're
going to try to get rid of the
filibuster mansion says he's going to be
against it i hope that's true
they're going to try to pack the court
they're really pushing that biden
doesn't want to do it but the people
around him really do
they're going to try to add new states
that would be radical it would give the
democrats a permanent majority there's a
ton
of support for that among the base i'm
not sure how much among guys like
manchin you know who might now be the
most
powerful people in washington
conservative pessimists say things can't
get any worse conservative optimists say
of course
they can and that i think is the my
cautious view
of the biden administration i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show